but hoksai the amazing artist has
returned to collaborate with silky
yeah
it's kind of sick sookie the greatest
clothing brand of all time
if you guys want some nice clothing
check out link in the description ken
felix
we've been called out
by darm
he's gonna make a whole special about it
oh god he
what the [ __ ] does this mean
darmian oh okay so you see wow how much
is that shirt 18 buckaroonies wowie
20 buckaroonies this one comes more than
the other one all right it's got the
white background now extra extra ink
gotta pay extra for that [ __ ]
premium baby all right dorman made a
response we made a video that i thought
was pretty nice we were pretty nice
yeah yeah we took it easy for sure we
held it back
but now
that he called us back
no restraints
oh my god breaking free who was this
months ago this is a forever go i
actually didn't want to make it home
like back and forth but now that you
know time has passed
emotions have settled hmm you know it's
time to rekindle it's time to
it's like the swedes
when the norwegians thought we weren't
gonna [ __ ] with them anymore they're
like oh they're pretty cool over there
we come back
what happened with the nori what
happened
okay you guys just get along yeah well
they took our oil again and then
as an american understand that yeah i
knew we would finally find
the right way to explain it
anyway darmian video let's watch yeah so
you see
if you cheat
you'll never get ahead
and cut all right that's a wrap guys
nice job
hopefully devin finally learns his
lesson this time i learned my lesson ken
from that video never cheat
you never get ahead
you know from every production i've ever
been on it's never ended like that it's
never been like yay high fives always
been like finally god that took freaking
14 hours but not a garmin shoot baby
it's all like
[Laughter]
i wonder how much they pay the actors to
be on here unless they just you think
they do it for exposure
damn oh
sorry i just had like a twisted idea
that we would like pay them more and
just to begin our videos
it's the mr beast idea the negative mr
beast
they capitalism just buy everyone up
come on
no they would never do that because
they're part of the fam of course but
no you're right uh sets don't look like
this but that's fine okay
hopefully devin finally learns his
lesson this time well i mean aydah plays
the bully too yeah yeah oh no we should
do we should have where aiden is the one
bullying me right and then he learns the
lesson wouldn't that be like that's a
good idea that would be lit it's typical
actors thinking they're they know how to
write a script come on get out of here
saying this
idiots
how could they think that yeah all right
some random woman on scene my mom teach
me the lesson
sometimes i'm teaching you the lessons
but a lot of times i'm the one that has
to learn the lessons i have played
more karen's than i can
count that's true that's true because
the women in dormant videos are usually
the bad guys
thanks for pointing that it's becoming
self-aware
this is great he's actually just satire
satirizing yeah himself he's finally
done it oh which one was it i i watched
one and she was just like wow
it was a it was the gold digger one uh
where she leaves him because he didn't
get like her bag
and mary was like so there's two women
in this whole this whole episode the one
is the made up karen you know the this
demanding all the things and yeah it's
got to begin with and the other one is
just the homebody wife that just waits
on the man to do everything great
fantastic and the lesson here is just
get rich yeah exactly but you weren't
meant in the face rock video right uh
the girl just goes to whoever has the
money or in the car they're just like
exactly
it's just get money yeah that's the
lesson just get rich if you watch
that's all you need to know baby selling
the dream
yeah this reminds me we had some fair
criticism in our video and i wonder if
that will actually be addressed now that
we've been called out
now fair criticism never never never
never never negativity oh you don't
agree with me oh my feelings are hurt
how could you say this on your platform
pewdiepie uh well
because
yes your video sucks
if you have a second i want to talk to
you about a new script that he has oh
yeah
of course i'll see you guys later all
right for sure man
you killed that last scene man nice job
thanks
oh hey do you think dog want to be in a
vlog for my channel
yeah i'm sure you'd love to no
he does not want to be in your vlog man
step back step back darmian doesn't just
vlog with anyone you fool
stupid child back here in the background
here is nice i'm gonna give it a little
green you know
i like looking in the background of the
screen just finding things like that
piece of paper
no one put a complaint there let's get
real the immersion is ruined now i can't
watch this [ __ ] video anymore
oh god
i just love when you script fan or like
some sort of i don't know if his fanny
works with him but when this script like
fan interaction yeah like do you think
darmian would like be cool enough to be
in a vlog with me
yeah bro dormant's definitely the
coolest guy in the whole world
out there you can trust on him he's a
nice guy
it seems like a funny comedy sketch of
like you trying showing just how nice of
a person you are and you script this
thing where a fan wants to take a selfie
with you and you're like a selfie of
course
of course can i get you an autograph can
can you come to my uh i'm having a party
late you should come over
i mean i'm
doing thanksgiving with my parents you
should we should do a selfie over there
well to be fair you're also like
the only guy that i know that just tells
people no yeah
and you're like no and it's the best
even i'm like heck yeah man they're like
oh cool can you tell tell pewdiepie i
said hi i'm a big fan of him
do you know how much nicer it is to meet
someone and then we just go like uh yeah
cool i like your videos oh thanks
appreciate that thanks for watching uh
bling bom bling bung i don't know what
small talk hat works but it's better
than oh selfie cool
yeah cool you got what you wanted can i
leave now no yeah i realize i'm just a
token uh for your
social media clan all right cool
that you can actually talk to like a
normal party being that i am
so much felix i got so many feelings
about this you remember back in the day
when we all had to pretend that we were
really nice and humble people but now
we get rewarded more just to be like
jerseys yeah and yeah flex all the time
it was weird though
[ __ ] we can't get into this now we gotta
watch diamond video but you're 100 right
yeah
because i remember there was this
[ __ ] child that came to my house and
started pointing a camera at me and
interviewing me and i wanted to show at
that moment like i am i'm a good i care
about my fans
he traveled probably very far to meet me
and i just go like but you can tell i'm
just dying on the inside this whole time
because i feel i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing like the force like
forced to smile yeah exactly
yeah anyway andy darmian starman come on
darmian we gotta stay on track hey
what's up man here he comes hey hey
there really
can i be part of your vlog
dude bro you've gotta he's gonna wear
his own merch too yeah yeah
product placement
what's up you guys i am so so proud of
aiden it is incredible how how [ __ ]
dumb he is
sorry
i filled it
in those phone rings dude okay i know
i'm not a camera guy
i know i'm not a camera guy
i know
i have no right to say this but you
could probably get better quality off
your phone than that whatever that is i
love the viewfinder that's not even
flipped around so you can see
[Laughter]
you're never gonna make it you [ __ ]
idiot
you need a five thousand dollar camera
like i got [ __ ] that's why i'm
pewdiepie
idiot him you never make it in this
industry you don't even know how to flip
your [ __ ] do you find a dumbass
where am i going nothing to add
you know what i have to get this i'll be
back just give me one minute okay i'm so
sorry that no word dartmouth prioritized
his work over fan interaction i knew it
um
oh my gosh you ate him from the diamond
videos right we're stuck to your youtube
channel yeah you're one of our favorite
actors do you mind if we get a picture
no
no i don't
oh no not at all like no you can't have
a picture not not even one
no
i like this guy this guy's cool yeah i
respect that
he doesn't know how to work a camera
ruined his vlog
no not at all
oh what
our friends aren't gonna believe this
thank you so much
okay oh no he didn't what the [ __ ]
here's the haters that's you and me
which one do you which one am i again
well we
you'd be the the guy on the right
because he looks more like you right
i'll be the guy on the left because
that's pretty much what i look like when
i wake up in the morning and also i'm
taller so it would also make sense
[Laughter]
yeah one i'm so tall
tell me more about all you i think
actually there's a slope as well some
they shouldn't even oh you're even tall
yeah i don't think i'm standing on the
speed bump over there i'm just trying to
like tippy toe
you're barely been shot dude i actually
remember this dartmouth called me up but
where would you go with this joke
anyway
do you think people do this they go off
to people in his cringey videos like oh
you're that crazy partly like no adult
maybe another child would do this but
not old people these guys are obviously
like you know 30 yeah this is weirdos
aren't you did you see how could he come
blasting them yeah cody yeah you talking
to me [ __ ]
from them blasted blah
oh that's [ __ ] funny didn't cody do a
video with dartmouth then wasn't it a
whole wholesome thing oh i don't know
did he i saw that it was great yeah he
was like actually i respect it was kind
of difficult to make this
cringey it was very hard to make him
yeah yeah
oh my favorite channel to rip videos all
from heck yeah absolutely thank you cody
the thing is i saw that video and i
that's why i kind of thought like oh
like darmian is kind of cool with people
poke in front of him because obviously
he did this thing with cody but then
we'll see how this turns out i guess i
don't know it's confusing playing
actually uh cody and dara are friends
yeah
oh my god
yeah bffs
they're best friends
they're acting in all their videos
acting in all their videos is so bad
yeah well you're wearing an earring and
doesn't suit you at all
that reminds me of like the dude that be
at the gas station and ask for like a
dollar for gas or something
give me give me a dollar i get a pack of
smokes
people do that earring
yeah
but they're not doing uk do people not
like just wait at gas stations and ask
for money no we paying poor people here
in europe ken okay oh right well here in
america we take away their benches and
make sure we torture them as much as
possible yeah
okay
isn't the world a wonderful thing
is
uh yeah
are you serious
you probably don't even get any views
i like this guy
it's like a modern day
joker
he probably no way if i didn't watch you
he just got us two haters out here
hanging out in the darnman studios
parking lot waiting for you to come out
here
this is totally a real situation that
would happen
actually i just broke amelia's hats oh
my god i just broke a million subs
congratulations to two million
got him got him you'll never get the two
let's go
i bet cody ko would have said the same
thing
oh my god bet you never get the four
then [ __ ]
you get too close
uh i mean four is an amazing number yeah
wow this four million means that you
know do you think someone's really made
it on youtube if they got over four
million subs dude according to dorman
stats you are up in the heavens above my
doors
yeah yes finally
let's watch this kid quit because you
got bullied but you don't get why anyone
even watches those dumb stories they
tell
well you know what we say we're not just
telling stories we're changing lives
that sounds like some corporate
like it's a job all right what do you
want from me that's what i would have
said
i'm trying to get paid i'm trying to get
to 4 million subs what do you want no
or changing lives
come on shut up
[Music]
oh no
dude you're even more cringing person
[Laughter]
i like this guy yeah they didn't have
any more videos
changing any lives
no wonder so many reaction channels
clown these fools yeah we clowned them
yeah
my boy's right there
we gonna do cry oh dorman was right
there and he didn't stand up for him
yeah
you made it i'm so sorry about that i
had to
is everything okay
darm man you were standing right there
the whole time
you were literally right there
you are complicit you know that's what
they say with bully if you don't stand
up
you are part of the bully
are we bullies right now that's a darwin
video for you darm man
i feel like that's kind of like what
this video is going for is that it's
making reactions like we're the bullies
right yeah obviously yeah
where do you think this is going
i mean i feel like i had to say the
state the obvious you know okay all
right
fine i'm i'm fine are you sure should we
continue vlogging then no it probably
wasn't gonna be a good vlog anyway oh
for that camera quality i don't think so
kid you're never gonna make it with that
camera please you got a mill you got a
million subs you're getting views put
dartmouth in your video you ain't got to
work a real job who cares those two
haters said oh don't be don't turn this
around and be nice
take a lesson from the paul brothers any
publicity it's good publicity bad arg
you know whatever just take it and run
with it true
that is true they're still around and i
don't understand how so yeah bigger than
ever who cares
yeah
take the negativity make it your power
there you go that'd be my doorman video
if you ever get invited to anyone that's
pretty good
test your real script something must
have happened
hold on you're standing right there
called me cringe
why is that funny
who cares if someone calls he cringe
jesus christ
someone was mean to me on the internet
here
i like how the sun's gone down too this
shot took a long time to get
yeah i'm thinking something
inspirational to say as well
but i got nothing
you got nothing i don't know i guess the
way i see it is like with dumb comments
if you call me them
you're dumber
yeah oh like i'm rubber and you're glue
whatever you say to me bounced off and
sticks
no i don't know
don't don't write me comments it hurts
stop it don't call me critch thank you
man don't worry about those two guys
they're just two haters yeah the
important part is that there's so many
people out there that love you
no but it's more than that i've been
getting comments on my videos telling me
i'm a terrible actor and
saying all these horrible things
look
really
common
the imitator
sucks i love they just pull up dm hater
look
got him right here
i thought everyone just made fun of
doorman because of the yeah right and
the sketch and the concept and just how
the story makes no sense why are you
trying to pawn this off on his
he's literally using his actors as some
sort of ploy well to be fair i'm sure it
happens right but that some of the
people in part of his videos gets like
oh they're so cringed by other kids or
something but the reaction videos
like we do
at least as far as i understand or
remember we don't do that i'm still
wondering like what's the relatable
lesson that we're learning here like who
is this video for
is this for his viewers i don't think it
is i think you're right this is
literally just for us to feel bad
look what you've done reaction videos
us feel bad bro come on
all right we got well we don't know this
story is we gotta get through it
stop doing youtube
what
no way look i'm sorry you have to deal
with all that but that does not mean you
should stop making videos
yeah i mean i i try not to let it get to
me but
it still really hurts you know
i mean what am i talking about you're
tar man
everyone loves you
aiden do you really think that i don't
deal with haters too no this is
impossible
this is impossible
there's no way darmian has haters no way
he's like the ryan gosling of youtube no
possible
you do but uh
i mean you're putting out all this
positive content who could hate on that
a lot of people
check this out let's go there it comes
here we go what's wrong
it's just so bad it's basically like
wait who's this guy again i recognize
him oh
i don't know like what he's saying
though he's not going in he's i think i
lied his winter what's wrong with him
what is wrong with his
fringe factory of content how could
anyone say that how could anyone say
stop it
and then i assume you know pewdiepie
here we go
yeah he's like one of the biggest
channels in youtube
and he pretty much just made a video
blasting me check this out oh no there
it is
i'm super excited i like how they left
you out of this skin you're you don't
matter this is the best part i can
pretty much say whatever i want to say
and everyone blames you for it
[Laughter]
doesn't make any sense i didn't think it
would annoy me so much
keep changing lives how dumb i hate it
yeah
yeah we didn't say anything about dharma
himself we criticized the video and i
think it was fair criticism i genuinely
do i don't have anything against darman
and fate's rug for that matter as a
matter of fact
i don't know they're pretty mad about it
listen i get it it's not easy getting
criticism okay especially from someone
that is so perfect look i had a lot to
say in that clip they just showed yeah
did you hear everything i had to say i
went um
[Laughter]
they left you who's this guy only four
four million subs nah not him but you
know pewdiepie is
sure
he's talking trash he just went on
attack for no reason and no like no one
else has ever reacted to his videos i
can't believe it pulled out like the
three things you said about him
dumb i hate it yeah that was the video i
hated the video because it send like a
really bad message yeah well the whole
concept right yeah two examples i
literally deal with hundreds of videos
and thousands of negative comments that
are making fun of me all the time
i can't believe it i mean
when i just see a few mean comments
it ruins my mood
how do you deal with all this
by focusing on the people that love me
not the ones that hate me nice there you
go yeah that's why i commented on your
video and made this about it and that's
why he made positivity
and that's why
i just like the haters thing i it
doesn't get to me at all
definitely doesn't i don't make a whole
sketch about it to make me look like
that's what i think oh god that makes it
so bad
oh god now i how i actually feel bad
because because the the
like otherwise why would he have done
this yeah exactly
uh this video wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for you man wow good job you're
welcome today yeah you killed it man see
you later love you
bye guys be careful there's some weird
haters in the parking lot waiting on us
let me ask you something do you think
that they love you
no yeah oh okay so what about those fans
that took a picture with you earlier do
you think that they like you
yeah
no those fans are only after clown come
on
so he was aware that these people were
in the parking lot
maybe he's staged this oh it's like one
of these things like a plot twist amna
shyamalan twist at the end
they were actually fans all along
my god
you must get a lot of nice comments on
your videos too right
yeah
i i get so many of those exactly there's
so many people that love you out there
so please don't focus on the ones who
don't because you can't make everyone
happy
true how
you know what you're right i
i can't believe i was thinking about
giving up on my youtube channel
i was so focused
making freaking bang dude what are you
talking about why don't you think about
giving me that i'm happy to hear i am so
proud of you aiden keep your head up and
i'll see you soon all right thanks star
i mean really he doesn't have to quit
his youtube channel all he's got to do
is quit acting for dartmouth
oh do you have any haters you know what
you should do you should make reaction
videos to diamond videos and call them
cringy
well didn't sniper wolf with the same
thing she made videos about doorman then
she appeared in one now everything's
cool oh really
why is that why is everyone allowed to
make fun of her is that me what well
because he knows you won't show up
because you don't
care the other people can be like hey do
you want to be in a dormant video
because uh you know i've got a lot of
people watching you know could really
help you
oh yeah and then you're over here like
no i don't need you he's like
pewdiepie's mean to me
i made a video about how much i don't
care vlog that you're working on and
maybe you should talk about what you
just went through because i'm sure a lot
of people would be able to relate to
that
that's actually a really good idea
thank you so much for sure i'll see you
soon
there's a lot of people that relate
today i'm going to talk about something
i haven't talked about before mean
comments you won't believe what just
happened to me you see
he's a youtuber he's never talked about
mean comments
talk about
i love it i mean if this guy can just
start the video without processing
anything what he was just told i mean
that's impressive this guy's gonna make
this guy this guy's born to be a
youtuber he can just turn it on
and now my perspective is completely
different and i can vocalize it
perfectly there right away baby
i don't know why that it doesn't matter
but yeah good for him yeah how does his
end uh he didn't finally flip it around
just like he flipped the camera
he edits the vlog and uploads it onto
his youtube channel yeah to his surprise
the video explodes and gets millions of
oh
oh yes that's literally my reaction when
i get breaks out in the end as long as
you get millions of views and become
rich and everything yes oh take that
haters
the same freaking story over and over
again holy crap
because it's all that matters baby
i just love his reaction of literally
jumping out of your shirt when you see
the views like what is that what is that
is that
what
what 3.5 minute
whoa
oh
listen if he was a real youtuber he'd
have been tracking that he'd be exactly
why is it not going up fast enough it
gives you going up way more fast before
never satisfied
getting the confetti yeah i'm getting
confident
where's my recommended how's this going
where's this coming from coming from i
got traffic
with his friends and they openly talk
about their personal experience with
bullying and criticism
things get a little emotional i like how
they put that together bullying
increases it as raw and as real as
possible nice
over time aidan's following continues to
blow up as he openly talks about real
issues facing a lot of young people all
over the world the family just rushes in
oh
my gosh i love it
and then one day he happens to see the
they're guys in the parking lot
was so dumb
your acting was really cringe in that
one
the halloween one was the worst making a
constant amount of trash yeah right
but i happen to really like that one oh
yeah i really like that one wow
why are they just supporting taters i
love this
my favorite part about these guys is
they watch all the videos
they've watched all of them and then
they hang out outside their studio it's
great
yeah
are you okay with their biggest fans you
again i just watched that tennis video
you did worst one of all times
we watched them all bro you guys seem to
hate her videos so much you certainly
seem to watch a lot of them oh oh
oh that's what you said just so you can
see how cringed they are yeah
yeah
uh and what you guys say to me that i
won't hit 2 million subs well guess what
guess what better rub it in your face
three million subs
so
that you'll end up at four million
[Applause]
oh she's crying after that what the [ __ ]
they're terrible to work on darm man
said you know you need everybody needs
to quit if they're getting treated like
this geez [ __ ] sorry to go through that
are you okay
i'll be all right just
really hits my feelings you know
i've been having more and more people
making fun of me lately
how do you deal with it
well
as someone once told me
focus on the people that hate you
focus on the people that love you
because
you can't make everyone happy
wow
thank you darmian
thank you
i can't believe i was letting those
people get to me i can't believe it
hey take my backpack come on
let's go record another vlog
okay
that way everybody
she's been crying her face is red why
are you why are you harassing this girl
leave her alone bro
do you remember because this reminds me
of especially how she looks like do you
remember rebecca black
do you remember rebecca blank
friday yeah
yeah yeah i remember yeah
like she probably became the most
bullied person on the internet well
the song is god-awful man and it's kind
of the same same thing like this random
guy in hollywood kind of like produced
it it's kind of his fault for making it
really cringe more than her she's just a
kid right yeah
but still
and also for the record this song
[ __ ] slaps anyway i i i
you see her now she's still uploading
videos she's gone through yeah she's
gone through this
which i'm sure was awful but she's gone
through like this the most so much
bullying that i can't imagine like a
single thing would ever bother her again
do you know what i mean
yeah she's got to be freaking like at
some point
she's got to have the fattest armor like
legendary tear epic tear armor on after
all this that she went through she got a
friday remix six months ago right there
oh she made another one where wherever
oh sh she made another one oh [ __ ] hey
oh
that is nuts
what the [ __ ] is this
oh they're doing oh my god they're doing
that
oh wow i'm so sexy now i'm twerking by
my car
and i'm sure she doesn't care
good for her
i guess my point is you know what
doesn't kill you make you stronger yeah
how do we get here you gotta be deal
with that you got to be able to deal
with some comments and you know what i
also did with a lot of hate comments and
you know what
it made me realize everyone else very
dumb that's the conclusion you should be
grateful that your videos are cringe
enough that it gets a reaction you know
well come on i can't be doing something
right i don't understand this logic now
i'm just trying to find some silver
lining before we get like a third no my
all right i guess my point is like you
gotta have some balls man
you
anything can hurt you if you get
criticism or mean comments it can help
build character i think it did for me at
least it helped me grow a lot of
confidence and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a bad thing
obviously commenting about people's
appearance and i don't know stuff like
that that's just blatantly bullying and
stupid and you shouldn't
have to deal with that but
criticism here on your videos can be
actually helpful it doesn't always have
to be bad or make you feel are you
saying that just can't take criticism is
that what you're saying but he should
actually listen from this reaction
i kind of seem like yeah
the whole goal that abuse abuses all
that matters yeah i kind of have a
problem with that way of looking at
things and in a way yes i do think so
but then again that's his opinion he's
right to have that and he's fine to
project that if that's what people want
to hear i don't really care but i have
there's also the right to call it out
because i think it's wrong here's my
thought right here
yeah the message
the message of follow your dreams and
you know keep doing you kind of thing
and you know screw the haters
the message is always good it's just
everything else about the video like how
they get there
you know
yeah you only you can only show your
haters if you're super successful and
all this like all that that's the issue
that's why everyone just makes fun of
them
it's because the packaging is just
smells like people are making fun of the
video not the people in the video we
know they're just actors and kids
right
our mansion takers are some
responsibilities
yeah
kind of kind of lame dude uh but other
than that i don't really care uh he's
free to do what he want i have nothing
against him i think it's called these
dudes trying to do positive videos don't
have problems with that but you know
you made it to a doorman video good job
i was sort of there but you did it you
did it you were right there with me
brother
you're right there with me
yeah that's it no uh no hate intended at
least to me it's a funny video to react
to and that's all you can't say don't
care because then they can say the same
thing we said about him oh you don't
care but you made a whole video about it
felix this is entertaining yeah that's
why
it gets my views
that's all right it's all about check
out kennedy today's your birthday
he's got positive videos
don't sit no hate don't send hate
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this